لا تزال اصداء فوز اردوغان تهيمن على
الاجواء في تركيا لكن الرئيس الذي اعيد
انتخابه سيصدم سريعا بوضع اقتصادي حرج قد
يتطلب اجراءات اليمه خاصه وان اردوغان قطع
وعودا بمليارات الدولارات خلال الحمله
الانتخابيه وضخ عشرات المليارات الاخرى
لتعويم الليره التركيه قبل الاقتراع اكرام
بما ان الانتخابات انتهت علينا الان ان
نسخر طاقاتنا للانتاج وخدمه الشعب
والتخفيف من اثار الزلزال وهذا سيكون
اولويتنا سنهتم بالمناطق المنكوبه وسنحد
من تاثيرات التضخم الاقتصادي على البلاد
ولن يكون ذلك صعبا علينا
[موسيقى]
شركه كابيتال ايكونوميكس قالت ان ساعه
الحقيقه قد تقترب للاقتصاد التركي فبعد ان
كان مدعوما بيد عامله رخيصه ونظام مصرفي
فعال غدا يعاني مشكله تسببت بها السلطه
التنفيذيه نفسها خلال خوض المعركه
الانتخابيه اتخذ اردوغان اجراءات ابرزها
حربه ضد نسب الفوائد المرتفعه كما قام
بتغيير حكام البنك المركزي النتائج كانت
كارثيه اذ هبطت الليره التركيه وتجاوز
التضخم السنوي الرسمي نسبه
85% في الخريف المشكله الاكثر الحاحا
بالنسبه لتركيا الان هي ان مصرفها المركزي
تنقصه السيوله فقد انفق البنك المركزي
حوالي 30 مليار دولار لدعم الليره منذ
ديسمبر ما دفع احتياطي اياه من النقد
الاجنبي الى المنطقه السلبيه للمره الاولى
منذ 2002
وغادر معظم المستثمرين الاجانب خوفا من
عدم الاستقرار فيما قدر خبراء ان حيازه
السندات التركيه من قبل حامل السندات
الاجانب انخفضت بحوالي 85% مقارنه معين
ويرى المحللون ان الحكومه التركيه لن يكون
امامها من خيار اخر سوى رفع اسعار الفائده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات